[Music]
good morning everyone this is Jeff from
the overwatch team we're here with
another developer update so one of the
things that we see you asked for the
most is new game modes and now I
remember back at Blizzcon I think it was
last year I was once asked are you guys
ever gonna do deathmatch and the answer
at the time was no we just didn't think
it was right for the game our thought
was that in both quick play and
competitive we always wanted teams
focused on objective based combat and
not off kind of doing their own thing
well things have changed we've
introduced the arcade last year and it's
been a really big success for us but the
coolest part about the arcade is it's
opened up our ability as developers to
introduce game modes to you guys that we
wouldn't normally feel comfortable
putting in the quick play or competitive
rotation so therefore the exciting
announcement is that deathmatch is
coming soon to the arcade and I think
you guys are gonna really love it so for
those of you who don't know what
deathmatch is it's probably one of the
oldest forms of FPS gameplay where the
simple goal is to see how many kills you
can get on the scoreboard and that's
right we've built a special scoreboard
just for deathmatch so you can know how
good you're doing in terms of kills now
there's two different ways that you will
be able to play deathmatch and I think
they're both awesome for different
reasons the first the core mode that
we're just calling deathmatch is
completely free for all meaning it's you
against seven other players in a map you
can pick whatever hero you want and I
guarantee nobody on your team is going
to complain about it all you have to
prove is that you can get the highest
score we usually play to 20 in these
deathmatch maps that you can get the
height the highest score before anybody
else now you might be wondering you know
in the arcade does that mean I have to
beat seven people every time to get my
win to count for my arcade wins each
week if I want to get my three loot
boxes well the way we handle that is if
you are in the top half of players and
in the
which in this case means you're the top
four you will get win credit towards
your arcade loop box but obviously you
really want to be that top player and I
have faith in you guys I think you can
get there I think you should really try
to be that top player so you might be
wondering like well where do I play
deathmatch all the maps are built for
escort or assault or control well we've
modified a lot of our maps not all of
them but some of the hybrid and escort
maps and some of the assault maps we've
modified portions of them to accommodate
this deathmatch mode and we think you'll
find it a lot of fun the other thing
that we're doing and perhaps most
exciting to me personally is we're
introducing a brand new map built
specifically for free-for-all deathmatch
now not only is this map have great
gameplay we've put some really cool jump
pads there's open areas for fara to fly
around tight reaper corridors for you to
mess around with the gameplay is great
but I think the story is really cool and
the art behind the map is awesome also
so the map is home to Amelie Lacroix you
might know her better as a Widowmaker
well previously before she was married
to Gerard Lacroix she was known as
Amelie gr now this is Chateau gr her
family estate in France and we think
you'll find it amazing and beautiful and
there's going to be slight hints about
her background and what she's currently
up to in this map so we think it's going
to be a lot of fun you have a new custom
free-for-all deathmatch map to play on
in the upcoming patch now the other mode
that we've added is team deathmatch and
this one's very simple to explain it's
just like the other mode except that you
and your team which is going to be a
team of six against another team of six
are playing to get to 30 kills and we'll
see who can get to that thirty kills the
fascist mercy resurrect does some
interesting things in this mode
it actually takes skill credit away from
the other team so someone like a mercy
is super valuable to have on your
team now the team deathmatch maps use a
different pool because we did a lot of
testing and we found certain things
worked and certain things didn't in team
versus free-for-all deathmatch for
example the Chateau was not particularly
fun for us to play team deathmatch on
but the arena maps like Black Forest
necropolis eco point Antarctica plus
some other portions of other maps that
we've done before like you'll you'll see
some of our modified CTF Maps
we're fantastic for this team deathmatch
mode so we hope you guys will play these
they're completely different than
anything we have an overwatch I like to
think of it as a great area to go and
blow off steam after a really tough
night of competitive matches or perhaps
you're just starting the night and you
want to get warmed up for competitive so
you can jump in and have some fun there
the game is completely different both
free-for-all and team will bring
different elements to you all I think a
lot of you who played old-school
shooters will really love the vibe that
the springs and more important to me is
that I look at this as just the
beginning of what we can be doing with
the game browser and custom game and
deathmatch as almost a platform so
obviously we have a very basic rule set
in there we let you pick whatever hero
you want you can actually skip the
killcam to respawn faster in this mode
which a lot of you will really like but
we're going to be looking to the game
browser and custom game for future
iterations of adding cool and new
interesting rules I think some of these
will be immediately available to you
guys for example one of the funnest play
tests we had we made everybody go McCree
for two minutes and we played all as
McCree and free-for-all deathmatch and
then after two minutes somebody called
out hey let's try out Hanzo is instead
and we all went to Hanzo I'd love to see
you guys trying this stuff in the custom
game browser and maybe eventually we'll
build more rules in the custom game
browser that allow you guys to create
more cool and awesome modes and us along
with you on that so anyway I know at one
point I said we would never never have
deathmatch in overwatch well
Never Say Never it's coming really soon
and we think it's awesome get out there
and enjoy it thanks guys
[Music]